welcome welcome welcome today we're
reacting to a video what a great intro
that was by the way today were reacting
to a video that even my mom sent to me
so you know it's pretty important what
Indians think of PD PI versus T Siemens
so far the Indians have been quiet their
voice have been silenced I assume by
t-series themselves but now thanks to
the channel Asian boss we will find the
answer like I said my mom sent me this
video so you know it's gonna be good
let's just find out what the Indians
feel about it hi
it's Chris from Asian boss even with all
the serious tensions between India and
Pakistan at the moment the online world
appears to be more interest in their
battle for YouTube supremacy as they
should I don't know actually I don't
know but they should this is what really
matters
okay worse are no longer fight through
soldiers and mercenaries they're
fighting through nine-year-olds we're
talking about PewDiePie versus t-series
the question is do Indian people even
know who PewDiePie is how big is
t-series in India our Asian boss
reporter Manisha hit the streets of
Mumbai to ask these hard-hitting
questions these are hard hitting
questions yes finally we will know I got
I'm actually nervous have you heard of
the brandy series yes obviously yes I
don't know if I like how they refer that
obviously okay I bet most people find
out about tea serious things to me
anyway
if anything TC should be thanking me
viewers who might not be aware of these
theories can you briefly explain what it
fresh
their tribe music company we distribute
music albums and songs t-series the
biggest
you know database of all I thought I was
gonna say biggest youtuber but no no
their intro database that's right there
yep see instead of primarily music and a
lot of it is the favor of India okay it
is a music label which makes original
music oh is that what they do they make
original music very interesting I
thought you know they just copyright and
other people's music that's really
strange
how often do you come across these
series is a huge it is it it is a huge
brand actually most of the talk songs in
India are made by t-series I think it is
it has the biggest market share in with
the music industry in this country that
sounds awful by the way one one company
making all the music for India don't
like the biggest channel right now from
India that's right from India they keep
leading up to something
but no it's the biggest channel from
India that's right that's all you're
gonna get t-series let me do movies and
don't make me come to India by the way
everything is released via PC DS DT DS
is that one music destination well okay
all right yeah how about a new song or
anything the only destination you'll be
going to the for the first place will be
t-series I know that a lot of people who
watch you know a lot of in you know
videos and conveniently it was about
saying hey music Bollywood music they
watch TCS on a daily basis and I know
for a fact that one of the biggest
YouTube channels in the world is TCH an
emphasis on one of okay why do you think
the series is so big Ananda
oh okay first of all like the YouTube
algorithm alright
this kids this kid knows what's up it's
the YouTube algorithm that's all there
is
I like this kid finally someone speaking
some truth here okay before sleeping be
videos Rd right if they come up they
pose like 20 minutes a day YouTube it's
like oh yeah we need to purge this no
human being can push to any videos a day
is the only advantage they have on me
catches on they come up with music that
people really like so
that is the basic reason okay fair
enough alright I don't want to keep you
know something on t-series I I can
acknowledge that they do make music
videos I I will acknowledge that they
make videos Pete is keeping me in a
musical life giving the newcomers a
chance in India because music connects
the whole world that's what I understand
any kind of art form connects the old
boys it's like lasagna connected
literally everyone even Indians are on
our side thanks to be society's not
wrong
I just realized tea service is a music
company and we absolutely stomp them by
making a song that actually makes it
even funnier I never thought of it
because it's been closed for the longest
time yeah that's right a long revelation
when it comes to their quality of videos
and personally I alright this whole quad
who cares about quality anyway I got
great quality here you see the Lightning
everything is top-notch that's why I got
great quality okay stop
I do like I'm a fan of Bollywood so it
becomes automatically become a fan of
t-series personally are you a fan of TC
know the view I don't like Indian music
sedessa there is how subscribe your
channel and I want them to be
when you stumble a channeling you do I
don't like you yes there is hope guys
there is hope if you thank him ago CC
diesel because of you today
Oh what did I say what did I say TV
series should be thanking me for
introducing them damn that's awesome
they actually found like fires
yeah beautify the Swedish creator who
post is meme reviews and make a lot of
fun content for the youth I don't know
about him people who do gaming what a
model pub general like a sausage with
these kind of things might know about
him otherwise thanks for girls
what do you mean girls are friendly now
what do you don't speak for all women
okay I have plenty of why I man who
watches me what's up ladies I have a lot
of them okay and I don't need this judge
I mean blankets Swedish guy but cute
light-colored eyes and he's very pretty
[Music]
beautiful
her she just changed she was like yeah
it's 60 million plus I just check
oh it's 87 million see that's what I
said 60 million plus famous do you think
beauty buzz in and oh dude if I is
actually very popular in India like I
was told my friends watch his videos
what's up my indian bros big shout out
thank you very much that's awesome
I didn't know that that's so weird to
think about people like so far away in
the Li on the planet Earth
watch your Swedish little idiot I
appreciate thank you guys
that's so weird that's crazy that's
crazy to think about dude if I his silly
stupid fun
he makes fun so fun of himself and oh
those I like his humorous simple silly
and stupid is that what he said I mean
he's not wrong damn I didn't expect like
such nice comments he has nice jokes and
release daily so - if my mood is bad I
can just look at my mood good so I was
it I wasn't ready for the feels that's
so nice hey we got blue blue shirt kid I
am subscribed to him for the meal for
the baby
the only reason I'm not subscribed to TC
reason because I don't want 20 videos a
day blocking - yeah damn right this kid
is the best in my friend circle he's
pretty famous because we all have been
falling in since a pretty long time
since the brofist time thank you
Oh G Bros from India that's awesome this
is so crazy how do you think find these
people that's a familiar with the major
online battle going on between DC's and
purify yes this is I mean don't do that
obviously that would be cheating and I
don't condone that behavior whatsoever
but that's awesome it's been going on
for like months now yes it everybody's
it verified like everybody's jumping
into it for views and everything I am
back what's your understanding of the
situation
so basically PewDiePie is right now the
most subscribed channel thanks righties
is the most subscribed channel because
excuse me excuse me I think that's where
you're wrong kid that's where you're
wrong it will never happen bro army too
strong okay
which they have in India it's like the
Battle of subscribers right now
PewDiePie has been campaigning to retain
his number one position but the series
is right behind him
I wouldn't say right behind I would say
like if I look over I'd be like at
whatever you know were you being chased
by so yeah we all can relate and you
look over and like oh god it's more like
a yeah I can keep going it's fine
that's how I would describe it but
that's just me of course so just for fun
who are you more inclined to support in
this life oh it's about to go down into
support pcs damaged I don't want to say
I'm holding that above and position you
want ec yes more inclined to see their
antennas fill my childhood when I was
five or six years old and now I'm 24 23
then it's very good I need to fact-check
this series when was teen series founded
it sounded like a lie 1983 okay fine
fine whatever like who's counting and
though why not beautiful because I'm not
interested in gaming at all and he
called me I called t-series a business
idea okay bliss that's not even in it
I'm sorry I'm sorry
come back to me I'm sorry for calling
you bases I although foreign youtubers
are on side of PewDiePie and I also I
also inside a few jeepers because I
don't like Theseus personally this
independent creator is still PewDiePie
so it doesn't make a difference and even
if he is not he's making the same
content it doesn't matter if he's like
above or below TC reason
not to me a dance this is so cool these
CDs is just for singing random videos on
the internet and becoming the biggest
you do plan on the bed but that doesn't
really you know isn't fair for PewDiePie
because he's been working so hard for so
long individual youtubers like PewDiePie
t-series is a big corporation who have
they have like unlimited resources to
gain that's right I can't how can you
maintain his number-one position ok
just keep doing what he's doing right
now that it became de Beauvoir if I'm
really desperate I mean I'm not
desperate of course but let's say I was
desperate like what do i do then
t-series will have a good quality of
production but you can never beat what
PewDiePie other connection PewDiePie has
with his audience oh yeah much better
than like anybody so that is why he is
popular see I do not like I do not like
not appreciated at first it's a good
thing that being an individual person
but then somebody at some point of time
started p-series alone - right it's just
not like it just came to be a big
cooperation it started but that's not
necessarily true
okay a lot of companies start off really
big they have investors they have a lot
of people a lot of capital okay so even
though being an individual it's a big
thing but being a politician I think is
your enough to you know carry - so do
you see him holding onto his number one
position or will he be overtaken by TC
oh yeah I guess be overtaken versus
what because t series is becoming
popular and popular day by day so or
associating with more and more new
companies Bollywood companies I think
it's like it's very stylish to have like
a battle it's regularly the T series is
not the win because the Indian audience
is increasing so this model is from
India coming on the internet saying here
that t-series is going to win he does
not actually care about her tribal and
he's not doing it like he has no
personal grudges honesty series it's a
TKO I lost some people get it and some
people are like it's a barrel he called
me Sonia so if we cross him I
think it'd be tough to compete as an
individual you have a hard time if we
cross him and he become number one
t-series are still continuing to grow
because India geo whatever for a global
viewers who don't know what gos can you
explain basically geo is a Wi-Fi company
that's offering like Wi-Fi at really
cheap hours now
so like a lot of India is now suddenly
on online damn this kid is so smart
YouTube higher this kid okay so
basically India is getting internet
which is a good thing obviously I
wouldn't joke like oh that's so bad but
honestly that's terrible
so basically India is getting internet
and t-series dominates India obviously
with it as soon as you make an account
in India I tried this out myself
you'll just be blasted by t-series
videos they have a huge advantage there
but sooner or later they will run out of
Indians and there are forever infinite
nine year olds do you see YouTube as a
space where it's the platform for big
corporations to run ads or is it a place
for creators to you know create content
actually both if you create content
people are attracted and when people are
attracted then you can earn money by you
know showing ads YouTube is encouraging
a lot of creators in India and the
corporations are also using it for that
business used to be a individual creator
content thing but now with like
monetization and things
definitely moving towards that's right
company saying and you might say you
know what there's nothing bad with that
and companies had the same set of rules
that applies to everyone else
but I think it's more a concern from the
community of YouTube's been shifting
towards less creator focused for years
now and now seeing an actual company
taking over as the biggest channel
people feel like that's a a symbol
almost of losing that another touch of
the creator side of YouTube creators is
why people love YouTube and that's what
created YouTube and I people want to
protect that I understand that I don't
think necessarily t-series is the fault
for all of it obviously that's not how
it is but I think that's why especially
people are so caught up in this battle
so interesting to watch this really like
it there you go
we used to get more content that we
can't get now everything is getting like
into the same algorithm like nervous
1001 tt over quality that's what we're
getting now so the battle was supposed
to be between PewDiePie versus t-series
but the narrative has kind of changed
and moved towards India vs. PewDiePie
know what you have to say about that how
it may be because of youtube I said a
few things that I have heard a few
Indians but it's ok no a few but
PewDiePie
that is very I found it mission vision
not people should follow these series
not because only for the his
I think these series have done a lot for
as for the country also someone in favor
of what he said completely because at
the end I mean in general tourism lies
in to me the concept of nationality does
not come anywhere close to YouTube like
being an Indian I can support anybody I
want it is my content it's not that
Indian people only like this you know
true Indian people like PewDiePie
everybody like it's about the content it
is not at all related to your
nationality and getting patriotism
inside it which is very dumb damn that
was an amazing video thank you Asian
boss go check them out link in the
description obviously for making that
that's so fun what a great insight it's
cool to see the kids so smart and hurt
yeah like articulate knowledgeable it's
so awesome and everyone that supported
me as well or even if like I don't know
in between us all I thought it was
really cool great video really enjoy it
I hope you guys enjoyed as well smash
like subscribe check out the merch and
as always see you guys tomorrow
holding after bro faced another couple
days at least minimum by tuber simulator
it's now so relevant that it's got a
brand new minigame Craney egg drop the
crane and get fresh items only available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys legs
[Music]